I proper to say if you are driving
around or wherever you are listening to
this show
park the car you're not about to get out
of it if you're watching then you know
to my right sitting here to kick off our
number three are two guys who I love and
know very well my compadres from NFL
gameday morning and guys who I will be
on NFL Network with in about three hours
time at 5:00 Eastern Time a two-hour
long show about the quarterback class
that's coming in and the quarterback
class that's about to change locations
in free agency when the new league year
hits in two days
two days in the National Football League
my coach Steve Mariucci and Pro Football
Hall of Famer Michael Irvin good to see
you guys great to be if we missing
somebody Curt welcome alternate air
right now he's in the air on its way you
know and I think it's you know look I
love Kurt he called him when Suze was in
this chair or a week ago today as a
matter of fact when I was at the combine
revealing my sub six 40-yard dash time
Congrats on that thank you thank you
why don't you say congrats on that and
Butch looks at me I understand the guy
who stretches your Igor that you got a
stretcher me tell you something
this guy is rig bonafide lead pipe
wielding professional who keeps this guy
I did not see herb with a back brace all
you're right goes out probably around
late October early November every year
so I will come in to Freddy Sanford so I
got this guy he stretches all the guys
all the professional guys in Dallas and
and he was stretching yeah for Michael
Johnson performance yeah so look at me
I'm like I'm performing very well but so
before so Kurt Kurt's coming here and he
called him for Sue's but he's never
physically been here and part of it
might be a good running joke if he never
shows up here you know what I mean
but I would love to have him here too
I'm kind of on the fence yeah TV and
what's not we should keep him away okay
so we're gonna be on the air tonight
again at 5:00 Eastern Time to talk about
the quarterback class and we're gonna
get all into that here on the show but I
do want to turn it over to Chris
Brockman at the
of our number-3 where we already had
Dwane Brown and Grant Hill calling in to
get a news update
brought to you by our friends at Honda
[Music]
with the news it's the Honda dream
garage spring event that's bringing you
Brockman's news update the best thing to
happen to spring since well spring
training you can get a great deal on the
stylish 2018 Civic check it out at your
local Honda dealer during the Honda
dream garage spring event right now
mooch ERV you've got an audience I know
I love it actually this is the perfect
audience Friday night guys let's talk
NFL first a very disturbing
controversial video of Odell Beckham was
making the rounds on social media showed
Odell on a couch holding what appeared
to be a cigarette of some sort and a
female with appeared to be some illegal
substances just wondering what you guys
thought of this video if the Giants
should trade him because of this video
or is he costing himself money because
of this all the Giants say they're aware
of it and they're not commenting on it
right now and you know it is something
else
Irv I just want to throw it to you first
what you think of the Odell I assume you
saw it's just two seconds it's very
quick it's two very you know he's also
making a suggestion to the disturbing
yeah I saw it and honestly guys when I
saw it I was like oh my god and and to
be totally honest with you you know I
did I got went back I thought oh this is
going to be bad I mean you know I said
Monday by the time Monday comes around
everybody grabs a hold of it grabs a
hold of this this is going to be bad and
I felt for him because I know you know
he's certainly not shouldn't be in that
situation I'm sure he doesn't he he's
going crazy now that all this this out
but but man I thought oh man he's just a
kid making a bad decision here and
things like this once they're attached
to you attache to you for life you know
it's just attached to you for life so I
felt bad about the whole situation what
do you thin right there what do you
think schirmer's doing today Steve if
you yeah but do you think Pat schirmer's
doing today what would you do it if you
got it well I mean you're gonna play
funny you're gonna talk to Adele and see
what's going on and
you know try to get a an idea of when
and what occurred you know I don't know
how many years ago or we got though that
was he tweeted about that right like he
tweeted out that you know past something
about pass intimating that that that
happened a little while ago or whatever
but I don't know how much that's gonna
make a difference
yeah I'm sure Pat wants to stay out in
front of it and find out you know more
of the details well I mean his he's got
a he's gonna be signed at some point in
time all I know is this is you don't
know when it is okay and yeah Adele
tweeted out old news still makes a good
story I guess what guess what if the
Giants decided not to sign him today
I proper say this 31 other teams lined
up for him yeah yeah do you think so or
no yeah well you know this kid that's
right ODL is going to have to go deal
with the people in the program with the
NFL just from that video I don't care
where you said that video was taken what
many was taking why I was taken you are
now going to deal with those people in
the program no even though oh yes yes
possibly interested or anything yes hero
law is closest to the stuff yes you are
you are dealing with those people now in
that program make no mistake about it
that's just how they do business
any little thing will get you in the
program and then they give you those
tests
you know those tests no matter what you
can't pass it it's one of those tests
where one two three four five one tell
me when you drink the most or five when
you drink the least and and you just
they ask you all those questions you you
can't pass that test
seems like you don't I drink when I am
sad one sometimes two or three most of
the time for a lot five every day just a
lot of NFL player news here Oh
most of the NFL stuff okay non NFL stuff
okay Tom Brady's Tom versus time
finishes yesterday the final episode on
his Facebook page and he was on Good
Morning America today talking about his
possible retirement with Michael Strahan
you have your wife you have your kids
you have to find that balance when it
does become time to retire how much did
that factor to your decision
well that that would be a big part of it
I think you can't make decisions
necessarily just for yourself and I
think that's one thing I've learned is
I've gotten older it's there's there's
some you know collateral effects to
every decision that I make in you know I
have a wife that is very you know
aspires to be a lot of things and she
travels a lot and you know our kids my
oldest son lives here in New York and
you know three kids and and you're just
always trying to juggle and you want to
be there for them and you want to be
there for the hockey games and the
soccer games and you know but you also
realize the level of commitment it takes
to to give as much as you can to the
team that needs you so again I think
you're always trying to find that any
most professionals probably feel the
same way it's sometimes it gets out of
balance and you got to figure out how to
you know bring it back to a point where
it feels great for you know for
everybody involved it's begun the the
concept of mortality we had Gotham
Chopra the creator a director
cinematographer of Tom versus time in
that seat you're sitting in mooch on
Friday and he said that this episode
that dropped it they ends where he's
seriously starting to wonder how much it
takes to continue on with this thing I'm
just wondering if that's just a March
post Super Bowl loss conversation and
what a lot of people thought about that
from the New England area talking about
retirement and all of that since that
long so I would imagine that that did
affect them some way you know and then
and then the Josh McDaniels take a job
don't take a job got fun and finished
business to go back but that Tom Brady
that's the first time you we're hearing
that right don't you think it's the
first time we're here yes I was going to
play forever and now it's something to
think about
so yeah that's pretty interesting how
much it all that has to do with him
setting up also now let's be real here
whatever meeting
conversations they have to have in the
big room over in New England they
haven't had that conversation that's
what I'm trying to talk about they say
that was coming and I'm sure it's coming
and there's a lot of stuff that's being
floated before meaning what that I'll
walk away if I don't like it
and leave you leave you with Brian Hoyer
you know I still think he wants to play
though right I mean you don't think that
this is gonna be a 2018 maybe or maybe
not I think this is like over the
steering wheel
maybe next confident playing his last
contract etc etc I think we know him
well enough that he's so competitive
that he doesn't want to end like that
and quickly he's what you probably wants
to aspire to win another one which they
can when they get Edelman back they
might be better but what you know you
know when you're young or you make these
professional decisions where do I want
to play and sign and all that now he's
making some family decisions that
doesn't surprise me
they're you know they've got kids that
that to consider and and his wife and so
that's why the New England's got to
draft a quarterback this year
you got to draft a guy I don't know if
it's on the 31st pick in the draft right
rich but it's they got to get a guy that
will be the heir apparent well I'm and
we're gonna hit that a little bit more
not only later on the NFL Network but in
our next segment what else do you have
over there Chris Pratt news first
reported by me last week Tiger Woods is
back guys second-place finish at the
Valspar this weekend what what a story
what a weekend for Tiger he's a second
favor to the Masters now he's a favorite
to win next week he talked about his
round over the weekend I had really some
nice building blocks at Honda and it's
you know I've made a few tweaks for this
week and is paid off and I hit the ball
well I made some putts this week I've
been here before a few times and so it
felt very comfortable and my game was
was quite solid this entire week as a
whole I felt very very good about what I
did this week
i cain't how great was I know mucha
already discussed in the last segment
but you you caught the end of that too
I called psycho I called it man I was at
the jump you know you are watching the
German it was back to what you used to
see you know how when Tigers out there
doing well you can be anywhere and
everybody has it on TV
and and they're watching and and it was
getting back to that where everybody was
tuning in trying to see if Tigers really
coming back it was it was cool to watch
when he dropped that 44 footer on 17 to
bring him with in one stroke to give us
all the the hopes that he could do it on
18 when he dropped that I'm like okay
you know he's in he's knocked the rust
off of his back injury and it was a long
game and his short game is getting there
he still just has that big moment
ability when he dropped that and then I
forget who was the announcer on NBC did
we find out it was Gary Koch was that
who it was think sighs as he's lining up
the putt from like what was it 39 feet
to try and get on 18 the the announcer I
think was Gary Koch just says run a
quiet moment
can't do this Kenny perfect reaction
he's not gonna be able to do this candy
but the answer is yeah maybe who's the
most clutch guy you've ever been around
you golf
rich yeah why do I do the combo off I do
the combine that's just close to not
what here he is running the 40-yard dash
who was the who was the most clutch guy
you've ever been around Steve clutch guy
yeah who's that been she's been around a
ton of them beers I suppose Jerry Rice
he's pretty clutch wasn't he when he
when he won it was all when it all came
down to it yomo how about you well you
weren't around Montana where you know
young rice like that kept just that
place you know the Cowboys against the
Cowboys play right there that's like a
clutch to me right there you know what I
mean it was at the end everything going
out on Tanner yeah my plan what about
you plan Oh
remove yourself from the oh he's the
most clutch guy yeah we're played
against I would say Emmett Emmett was
that's why I tell people I don't love
bears said I would take Emmett Smith
over anybody anytime
Batman it was a beast man I mean a beast
and it was a funny do too you know I
would be in the middle of a game and
Emma made some incredible runts with his
balance when you think he'll be hitting
the ground comes up out of it I said man
it was an incredible run and I'm looking
at dude I said crap I can't believe what
I just saw he was like you shouldn't
have seen it you should have been
blocking somebody anyway yeah it would
have to be that guy he's collect all
right good news update you got one more
on event you want to see yeah I got one
more cool baseball story the Baltimore
Orioles announced today they're doing
something called kids cheer free in
which parents can bring children aged
nine or younger to games for free every
parent advised to regularly priced upper
deck seats get two free tickets in the
upper deck for their kids program runs
month-to-month okay try to get younger
people involved are cheering for major
league baseball upper deck and then for
their home games when the Yankees are in
town just keep them away from the right
and left field seats
let's get them safe and safe that's
smart you got a recruit under 30 home
runs for judge this year under 30 yes
you're just saying that cuz John
Sterling's on tomorrow show you just
getting ready oh yeah good Honda News
Update sir
appreciate that okay mooch is here Irv
is here when we come back let's start
digging into the quarterback stuff you
know it okay and obviously it starts
with number one overall does the these
are all tease questions don't answer
them does the tie rod taylor acquisition
change the way that the browns are going
to go ahead and handle the top of the
draft and then what are the Domino
effects from there on out Kirk Cousins
is obviously gonna change addresses by
the end of the week okay Casey has made
some cuts the Dolphins are supposedly
gonna cut in Tomic ensue so much to
discuss here with Michael Irvin and
Steve Mariucci were on the air with Curt
Warner and a cast a thousands on NFL
Network on these very subjects at 5:00
Eastern Time that's later on this
edition of the Rich Eisen show
just a great time of year brackets are
out Michael Irvin's canes are in the
tournament playing in Dallas which is
good free very geographically sound free
there Tiger Woods with a great weekend
baseball pitchers and catchers reporting
we all know what's going on in the NBA
right now the hockey playoffs are around
the corner and then the NFL comes in
sometimes and just absolutely stomps it
all out of the headlines because the
Browns do something like they did on
Friday
Irv you first what do you think of the
Browns moves on Friday acquiring Jarvis
Landry for a four this year seven next
Tyrod Taylor for three this year and
then they went ahead and traded to Sean
Kaiser away for Randle a cornerback from
from Green Bay what do you think of
those incredible first of all you know I
just just the move that they are making
or saying something and the talent
didn't have oh love Jarvis Lynch I love
the dog and Jarvis Landry you know and
I'm telling you I want red pants today
too rich just to talk about this a
little bit because as people I wear
green suit later because that's what
it'll be about money how much money
people make right now there's a decision
that people have to make on their
football teams right now and they'll
make decisions off our well people run
how much I'll bet not well they catch
and all it is how well they play
football but I want you to make sure
that you stop that's what Raiders for
stop and think about the locker room how
well that guy works in your locker room
aren't any guy that you let go how well
how much will that hurt your locker room
Jarvis Landry is one of those locker
room dudes you warned him in your locker
room he lost football
I think Cleveland it's done a great job
so I didn't want Miami want him in their
locker room anymore customizing a
culture yeah I don't know what's going
on in my and dhama can Sue's about to
hit the open right in a couple days to
is you're supposedly he's gonna be
released and there's a couple days that
you and I talked about that was that you
and I talked about the thought of Jarvis
Landry and Josh Gordon yeah I thought of
you right away the word physical jumps
to mind an in-joke go on top each okay
that's incredible right there man if
Tyra I tell you can't touch them with
the ball they'll have something don't
the Browns are won in 31
couple years that's true you bring in a
guy like John Dorsey comes from that Ron
wolf tree he's not messing around he
says we're gonna get better and we're
not gonna just do it from the draft well
draft well yes but we need to add some
players that get it right and you're
talking about
Tyrod Taylor took the bills to the
playoffs this year for the first time in
forever and the Browns haven't been in
the playoffs and what 15 years or
whatever it is they're a better football
team right now much better right and
they still have all these draft choices
they didn't they still have two ones two
twos I mean they read to thank Craig and
they've got they've got some ammunition
to keep maneuvering a little bit it's
gonna be fun just to watch the Brown
love and I know it's hard but I'm
telling you and I said there's a couple
I said this before they went on in 16 it
I hope the Browns give it just a little
time with hue just a little time and
they've done that you know what I mean
cuz I brought back a team coach to win
or 16 to get they're giving us some time
and now giving him a second run I can't
wait to see what happens so the question
is Irv and and mooch is that how much
time is Tyrod Taylor gonna have do you
think Steve they're still gonna with the
first overall or fourth overall pick
choose a quarterback I don't think in
the first pick they need to know right
the barkley kid yeah we all fell in love
with the kid just watch them listen to
him you know what I mean he's not only a
great kid a great player he's gonna be
the great face of any organization you
got to have him in Cleveland right
that's that's my thought and then the
fourth if their guy if they in their
evaluations of quarterbacks if they have
one that's just heads and shoulders
above the others figure out a way to get
that guy for your future but if it's a
coin flip between Allen and Rose and in
a and Arnold they're going to get one of
them at four easy I mean it's gonna be
sitting right there for them and then
they have to decide do we do that or do
we get a chub or do we get somebody else
that starts Tyrod Taylor can do this for
us while we're building up our team
maybe they get another guy in this
second round or later use those twos and
move up and go get a another good
quarterback whether it's Mayfield or
whoever they've got so many ways of
improving their team and getting that
quarterback of the future well Tyrod
Taylor plays and holds down the
for a while would you do what I've been
pounding the table for the Browns to do
which is use all of some of the
ammunition that they have still I mean
they could trade they could trade a
couple of tubes if that's what it takes
and still have a two for the second
night to trade up from four to two and
just get both and not even risk it get
your top quarterback gets a qualm
Berkeley will see a Friday night for one
pick and then we'll see you on Saturday
and then we'll see in the fall Oh would
you do that probably not I'd probably
like answers that somebody's gonna be
there for if you but if you had now if
you had that quarterback that was in
here that I mean you know if in the
Andrew Luck that was in here right now
hmm then you say yeah who do you think's
closest who do you think was closest to
that based on the evaluation so far I in
the sky what we saw at the combine Steve
some of these guys on a grease course I
did and I and I hate I hate ranking the
quarterbacks
but at some point I know did you meet
all of them no I didn't meet all of them
so so I met some of them and so you know
but darn 'old probably would be that guy
right now based on everything I know the
potential the arm the size is skill set
probably him but if the if the Browns
think that there are two or three or
four guys in there that could very well
end up a starter for them then they just
sit and let it let it play out and use
all of their picks because they'll get
somebody at four they could use the twos
and move up and get somebody later in
the first round but but if they have a
conviction this is our Andrew Luck or
this is our guy then you got to find a
way to get em in the mats this question
and we'll take a break talk Cousins and
the rest of the free agent market let's
say the Browns do take say Kwan and they
don't do what I advocated which is blow
the Giants away do the Giants take a
quarterback attest a war that's going to
be interesting to see right there will
the Giants take a quarterback with all
their Eli's Eli and everything that's
happened
that'll be interesting to see III don't
know whoever it is if they do he's gonna
sit around on the bench just like this
he's gonna sit he's gonna sit for a
couple years yeah right so so maybe they
take dose it right now but if you'd like
it's on one of those interception sprees
you know those people in New York he'll
be called in for that kid time when he's
Superbowl that's one of Earth's favorite
pastimes on game day morning here on the
Rich Eisen show and then later on today
no doubt just love and just one minute
when Eli's on the on on the table on the
docket for conversation no and he backs
it up by saying he loves Eli you talk
about every room you asked a question
about clutch that's the name you can
throw out Eli's been clutch okay and any
time when the term moment is right and
Eli he will be clutch and then where's
the B word Dallas Cowboys news that
might not MIT mr. red pant might not
even know about it see how he just
coming up in 60 seconds we'll talk
cousins des that news and some more when
we come back with Steve Mariucci and
Michael Irvin on the Rich Eisen show
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
Steve Mariucci and Michael Irvin still
here for another segment I'm a fired up
we're gonna be heading up the 405
together to go to NFL Network for a
quarterback 18 show 2018 with the free
agent class and then also the incoming
rookie class mooch Irv right here Kurt
Warner will be joining us later on
Orlando Scandrick according to Todd
Archer oh and wants a release in what's
his release that's a project we're gonna
be making some moves with oh they really
liked young secondary that they have and
and and always getting up and he's done
well with Dallas but I knew they
we'll be making a move okay so now I'd
like you to be my Jerry Jones whisperer
here what's that knowing him as well as
you know him and Steven Jones whisperer
and the Cowboys whisperer Oh everything
I'm hearing about des Bryan out of their
mouths we loved as Dez is great but I'm
reading between the lines here mm-hmm
Dez isn't as good as Dez used to be
anymore
Dez is expensive we need to talk to Dez
but we don't know how to talk to Dez
because we don't want to piss Dez off
because we still want Dez to stay we
want Dez to be cheaper yes Steve
Mariucci did you did I know you hit it
pretty good
you got all around it and everything and
it has been a lot of that out there
we've had a lot of conversations you
know we had conversations about that who
is the we we we we you and Dez we 88
Club cards i sexy I've talked with Jerry
and we spoke about the situation yeah we
have spoken about the situation now and
and they do want this back and
everything there's a there's a business
side of it and I'm gonna tell you I feel
comfortable about you know rich you're
in dictionary renditions there of Jerry
Jerry as years head to me Jerry and
Jerry and there's a tight you know Jer
is comfortable we're talking there's
about business and okay I mean they
they're tight tight I mean they saw how
the business besides this biz but des
does not seem to be at all interested in
taking any he's taking the right
approach they're taking approach that
they're taking their approach he's
taking the right approach e I mean I
don't know anybody wants to say every
time everybody asks me you won't take a
pay cut okay yes yeah to take that pay
cut face
absolutely the right way so then let's
get straight to the heart of the matter
is he the same receiver is he a number
one receiver in the national football
he's in the Morrissey so why isn't he
out a thousand yards since 2000 and of
course this has some injuries and then
changed a quarterback I think make sure
that makes a huge difference and
honestly honestly I think all of that
coming down at the same time kind of
plays on him and I want him to get back
to having fun playing football that's
when he plays his best football when
he's having fun and in that all and not
worry about this that's one of the
things I talked to Jerry about I say man
I I don't want to hear all of this
whatever you got to do let's go get it
done so we can get this down so you can
have a healthy team not just physically
but also mentally healthy going into
this season coming up cuz last year you
know you had healthy teams but they
weren't nearly healthy with all that
hung over the head of disease so before
we move on or one of the many kids that
you saw on the turf at Lucas Oil for the
combine working out a wide receiver they
needed to draft one of those for dough
yeah yeah which one which one intrigued
you let me tell you now I'm gonna tell
you something here and there were a few
kids they get Ridley if that's where
you're going yeah no no no we all love
really I mean let's see what Dallas trip
we all love Calvin really we all love
them we all love their 19th overall did
you hear what I just said we all love
like see ya back to the week you're not
getting them at night oh oh I don't
think he'll be available man he won't be
but now there are some other kids out
there you know that that I think that
would do well in Dallas and and I
remember talking about juju Smith
Schuster that's right yeah and this is
why I love when Coach and I used to do
Game Change because you really get
chance to work out with those kids up
front and and I'm talking about that
locker room presence in a locker room
and then kids like that but that's what
that's what Jarrod has raised to find a
guy that right now could come in and
play a number two spot today and take
over that number one let me give another
preview get rid of days and you don't
have
any answer for anything you mean you
couldn't have been the man you were
without Alvin Harper I understand
everybody a little bit more of a preview
but we're gonna have later on at a film
network I do believe this is the top of
our to opener
Steve Mariucci is Kirk Cousins a
franchise quarterback this is a great
coach a football league you want me to
say what I'm gonna say later on their
show sure you know what
so it's we are talking about this to it
the money he's going to command is
unbelievable I don't know where did he
go to school rich anyway right oh the
Michigan State University yeah so he's
gonna he's gonna leapfrog Jimmy G
because of demand because of the
position and is he a franchise
quarterback I say yes and I'll tell you
why Kurt Warner will say no he's not
because he never won a playoff game
right he's only been to one Pro Bowl his
record is such that it's just pretty 500
overtime right but I will say this over
the last three years at Washington which
is just an average football team all
right he is ranked in the top three or
four and many of the quarterbacking
statistics and game-winning drives in
yards in completion percentage in passer
rating in all these other things two
touchdowns responsible he has room the
tops he isn't the tops of all the
quarterbacks we talked about and so that
kind of puts you in that category well
whether you like him or not he has been
statistically their franchise
quarterback yeah call out people in the
names of athletes right now in sports
that are making over thirty million
dollars a year Steph Curry anybody
doesn't know anyone LeBron James Shaw
Clayton Kershaw okay
sorry Mike Trout like traffic is hard my
trout a cart doesn't you remember
watching Big Bird right Sesame Street
when they say
all of these things are just like which
one of these that really don't go
you know what any place and I'll have
the light on Kurt cousin in the box see
you like that you like the box that's
what I'm saying that's amazing good
since you like that game yes call Kirk
Cousins the MVM the most valuable Muppet
the market you know what you know what's
different cousins and all those other
guys you just mentioned he plays
quarterback well there is a premium
premium on that position in sports
because like the most difficult position
to play so if you are good first you get
it there's another difference those
other guys I met you there's some real
bad boys sports I mean they're the tops
of the tops in the tops of all that
sports and they're go Kurt cousin they
never won ten games in a year as LeBron
doesn't play quarterback Aaron Rodgers
leapfrogs him yeah one breeze breeze is
gonna set I mean and we had Thomas
that's my point if Kurt is worth 30 we
ain't got no money to pay Aaron Rodgers
and that's my point omission why should
air when he should begin 75 Thomas
Dimitrov for the Falcons says that he'd
love to get Matt Ryan sign but Matt's
chilling out seeing how the markets
being set by people who haven't even
made the Superbowl yeah and Matt will be
in the 30s and then when sand golf will
be in the 30s and then soon it'll be the
40 raisins the quarterback position they
so you're saying somebody in their 20s
is gonna be in their 40s one day in the
National flatly yes crazy talk
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience